Stephan Feuchtwang ist Brite
– fast sein ganzes Leben schon.
Geboren aber wird er 1937 in Berlin.
Mein Vater war Österreicher,
meine Mutter Deutsche.
Er war Jude. Sie war „Halbjüdin“.
1938, am Abend bevor
Nazi-Deutschland Österreich annektiert,
flieht Feuchtwangs Familie aus Berlin.
Mein Vater hat meine Mutter
in der Stadt getroffen und sagte:
„Geh nach Hause, schnapp dir
das Kind, nimm den Koffer.
Wir treffen uns heute Abend am Bahnhof und
fahren zu meiner Schwester nach Rotterdam.“
Am nächsten Morgen
– so hat es die Schwester
meiner Mutter erzählt –
hat die Gestapo uns bereits gesucht,
weil mein Vater nicht mehr durch seinen
österreichischen Pass geschützt war.
Die Nationalsozialisten nehmen
den Juden erst die Bürgerrechte
– und später Millionen das Leben.
Feuchtwang will zumindest
den deutschen Pass zurück.
Laut Artikel 116 des Grundgesetzes
können Deutsche und ihre Nachfahren,
die von den Nazis verfolgt wurden, ihre alte
Staatsbürgerschaft zurückbekommen.
Feuchtwang aber wurde abgewiesen.
Zu meinem Ärger wurde ich abgewiesen,
weil mein Vater Österreicher war.
Wenn er geblieben wäre
– ich kann gar nicht glauben,
dass ich das jetzt sage,
aber das stand so im Brief –
bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, an dem den Juden
die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft
von den Nazis entzogen wurde,
dann hätte ich mich qualifiziert.
Aber bis dahin wären wir
doch bereits tot gewesen.
Wegen vieler solcher Ablehnungen hat
sich nun auch der Deutsche Bundestag
mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt.
Der Brite Felix Couchman und
seine Frau Isabelle sind Gründer
einer weltweiten Gruppierung,die für weniger
Ausnahmeregelungen im Gesetz kämpft.
Sie waren im Januar in Berlin, um
der Debatte im Parlament zuzuhören.
Doch die deutschen Abgeordneten sehen
aktuell keinen Nachbesserungsbedarf.
In zwei zusätzlichen Erlassen
hatte die Deutsche Regierung
im August erst einige
Einschränkungen abgeschafft.
Couchman reicht das nicht.
Die Erlasse sind Ermessensentscheidungen.
Aber Artikel 116 ist ein Grundrecht!
Diese Menschen können ihre Lieben nicht
mehr zurückholen, die umgebracht wurden.
Sie können ihren Besitz und
ihre Jobs nicht zurückbekommen.
Aber sie können sich die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft zurückholen.
Jüngere Nachfahren sind ebenfalls betroffen.
Marcella Marx’ Großvater Georg floh aus
dem nationalsozialistischen
Deutschland 1937 nach Brasilien,
zwei Jahre nach den
Nürnberger Rassegesetzen.
Nun will auch sie die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft.
Ich dachte, das muss ich tun
– für die Ehre meiner Familie.
Sie waren doch so lange Deutsche.
Mein Urgroßvater kämpfte sogar für
Deutschland im Ersten Weltkrieg.
Marcella bekam zunächst eine Absage,
weil ihr Großvater Deutschland
angeblich freiwillig verlassen hätte.
Ihr zweiter Antrag liegt dem Amt
seit fast drei Jahren vor.
Auch Stephan Feuchtwang
will nicht aufgeben.
Mit der neuen Regelung kann nun
auch die Herkunft seiner deutschen
Mutter berücksichtigt werden.
Aber seine Geduld mit den
Behörden ist fast am Ende:
Es ist ein Kampf, in den ich
gleichzeitig sehr involviert bin,
aber auch jederzeit bereit aufzugeben.
Wenn die Bürokratie einem
so den Weg versperrt,
dann werde ich nicht weiterkämpfen.
Warum die Deutschen so vielen
Nachfahren die Anerkennung verweigern,
versteht Feuchtwang nicht.
Ihm bleibt nichts anderes übrig,
als erneut auf die Entscheidung zu warten.